MAX SALTONSTALL: Welcome to
"BeyondCorp in a Bottle,"
where we explore
journeys into the world
of context-aware access
and zero-trust networks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Most companies look at
security as a binary,
with the good
folks on the inside
and the bad folks kept outside.
So security teams install
various firewalls and VPN tools
to create a strong
perimeter, always
looking for taller,
thicker walls
to respond to the last type
of attack or compromise.
But this model
breaks down as soon
as things get more complicated.
Employees have to work outside.
Contractors need access to just
one or two internal systems,
not all of them.
Mobile devices aren't
compatible with your VPN client,
and attackers are
sneaking into your network
on previously trusted
devices, hiding inside
like a Trojan horse.
We've seen the reinforced
perimeter model break down
in many ways, exposing the
highly vulnerable interior.
So at Google, we
shifted to a model
without an inside
or an outside, where
we evaluate the trust of
each request as it is made
and test to see if we
should grant access.
All access to company
resources gets decided based
on the context of the request.
Who is it, and should
they see this thing?
What device are they on,
and do I consider that safe?
If the identity plus device plus
access policy all check out,
then they get it.
If not, it's an express bus to
403 town-- permission denied.
In this model, there's no
trust inherent to any network
or location.
So we don't care if you're
sitting at home, at a coffee
shop, or at the office.
You get exactly the
same level of access.
And it's easy to start down this
path on Google Cloud Platform
with Identity-Aware Proxy.
All you need is an app that's
using Compute Engine App Engine
or Kubernetes plus Google
Identities for your employees,
and you can start securing your
apps with identity controls.
To get more detail, check
out my post linked below
and subscribe to get more videos
on BeyondCorp, Zero Trust,
and Identity-Aware Proxy.
When it comes to protecting your
company, keep your data yours.
[MUSIC PLAYING]